hey youtubers is Charlie and Stanley
made his illustrious debut on agents of
shield and they introduced a major
character from the comic books it's not
a two-parter but the next episode is a
direct continuation because there was a
big cliffhanger since a lot of you in
the UK and other international countries
won't see this for a little while
careful for potential spoilers if you
don't already know who that comic book
character is so let's start with our top
five moments and then I'll do my review
number five maze wheels up I'm talking
about the whole reverse storyline aspect
to the episode I thought it added a
really nice touch to the story and it
was so much fun watching what happened
to me after she got knocked off that
train did you notice that that Mae story
was bookended by Ward's sex talk with
Coulson I got the sense that they really
wanted us to visually connect maze
intensity with her relationship with
Ward especially that torture scene which
made it a little bit freaky but it's a
nice reversal to see a female character
like her be so aggressive I've always
been a huge fan of Mina so it's awesome
to see her get to have so much fun on
the show as an added bonus her character
really does get all the best action
scenes number four Stan the man cameo in
true comic-book fashion Stan Lee serves
as the moral message of the episode his
comment to Coulson you've made mistakes
but you can do better is really just a
generic theme for all the characters and
the audience particularly Mike
Peterson's character Stan Lee was
actually really notable for including
those morals in his comic book stories
whenever he was editor at Marvel number
three strangers on a train
Coulson and Simmons epic blowout was a
lot of fun to watch I liked how they
paid off Fitz's earlier jokes about how
she is the queen of homework
the look on Coulson's face when she said
prostitutes was priceless though I can
just see the Twitter hashtags now
prostitute face number two
Simmons and Skye are pretty dead not one
but almost two deaths there were maybe
three game-changing events in this
episode and the sky and Simmons almost
deaths were two of them Simmons is just
frozen as a result of that night-night
gun gas but sky is bleeding out I
actually expected her to manifest a
power in that post-credits teaser so it
looks like she doesn't have any
resurgence abilities my earlier theory
and the one I'm still leaning on is that
she's a technopath
because I think it'll have something to
do with the clairvoyant and my number
one moment no surprise here Mike
Peterson becomes Deathlok I like the way
they explain how he's Deathlok basically
just by using that cybernetic leg in the
comic
folks the character is really more
machine than man Darth Vader style but
they opted to make J August Richards as
an actor looked more realistic
I'm actually calling that the Tyrion
Lannister move it's when a show
dramatically reduces injuries or
alterations to a character that would
make them have to wear these crazy
prosthetics or use special effects they
did incorporate some of the storyline
from the Michael Collins Deathlok in the
comic books he had his brain put in a
cybernetic body and was being controlled
by the machine parts eventually he
gained control of his body and then
became a SHIELD agent honorable mention
goes to Coulson laying the smackdown on
Ward if you remember he had that Emil
Blonsky shout out that's the Hulk
villain called the abomination the last
person to play that character was Tim
Roth during Incredible Hulk
let me know what your favorite moment
was and do you think this guy is going
to manifest a power in that next episode
personally the high point for me was
watching my Petersen become Deathlok or
maybe Coulson prostitute face
overall this is one of the strongest
episodes of the season I love the
narrative structure in the way they told
a lot of the story in Reverse they were
able to go really easily from
laugh-out-loud funny on the train to
almost killing two of the most lovable
harmless female characters on the show
it's like just Whedon hurting willow on
Buffy she seems so harmless so it twists
you up so much when you almost see them
die technically agents of shield isn't a
Joss Whedon show but if you're ever
watching something he did and you really
start to love a character start to worry
because something really bad is probably
about to happen to them I guess you
could also call that pulling a george RR
martin Game of Thrones shout out Stan
Lee's cameo felt totally appropriate he
does kind of seem like he's been play
acting Hugh Hefner and a lot of his most
recent cameos but the moral message he
delivered was very true to what he used
to do in the comic books one of my
favorite things about the episode is how
Mike Peterson's art just became one of
the most important things on the show
he'll be critical to them defeating the
clairvoyant but he started as this
throwaway extremist cameo so I'm
expecting something similar to happen to
Skye she's still in the middle of that
moment a horror you know when Mike
Peterson woke up in the bed missing a
couple limbs so expect Skye's character
to undergo a fundamental change when she
recovers I'm hoping that means that she
finds out what her powers are and starts
to use them it's like they show just
told us the only way to survive is
evolve and sometimes that means becoming
a cyborg sometimes it means manifesting
special powers that is why I love
science fiction so much big announcement
though agents of shield will not be back
until March 4th because
Olympics but when it does come back Bill
Paxton is guest starring as agent John
Garrett think of him as like a
cybernetic version of his character
Hicks from aliens
with less wisecracking in related news
they have also made some major casting
announcements for the flash TV show I'm
gonna do a special video for that on
Thursday be sure to subscribe to get it
it's gonna be really exciting I'm
getting so pumped for that show right
now click here to get last week's agents
of shield and click here to get my
latest arrow video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you